[Music]
hi we're live from the 2019 Wolfram
technology conference I'm Silvia Haas
and I do all the social media for from
research and I am the co-host should be
ponse and I was a Wolfram stew or a
student at the Wolfram summer camp this
year today we have soup Athamas
who is a software engineer at Wolfram
and he'll be talking to us about his
microcontroller cannon so what do you do
at Wolfram and what are you doing at the
conference yeah so I'm a mess you said a
software engineer and we have got Adams
R&D
I worked in the areas of control systems
and microcontrollers so in control
systems I primarily focused on classical
control systems and nonlinear control
systems I've been involved in all the
other areas as well
so my work in the microcontrollers has
now personalized into what is now a
microcontroller kids so can you tell us
a little bit more about the
microcontroller so the microcontroller
kit is a new feature that we at least in
version 12 so it automates the
generation and deployment of code to
microcontrollers so if you have a
controller or a filter in the Wolfram
language or maybe some model for
hardware in the loop simulation or it's
some data acquisition code you need not
manually write the equivalent
microcontroller code you can go directly
from the Wolfram language to deploy code
on the microcontroller he shows that
example alright sure so so we here
I have an atmega 168 microcontroller
so this one is the smaller sibling of
the atmega328 which is typically on
which is on the Arduino Uno so and what
I have here is a voltage regulator it
makes sure that this microcontroller is
getting constant and clean five volt
voltage supply are we here so so the
microcontroller has a notch here so this
cell we start counting the pins so it
has 14 on the side and 14 28 pins and a
dual inline package so in on that pin if
you count back was that spin 24 and you
see there's a green wire sneaking back I
have this potentiometer connected there
okay so this is an analog input to this
microcontroller and on on this pin 15 I
have an LED connected so I want to
adjust the brightness of this LED using
this potentiometer so then so that's
what I want to do so let's let's
let's look at the Wolfram language code
for that so I have this transfer
function model so what this does is fun
on this board I just want to take the
input and send it out to the output so
it's a constant gain one in case you're
not familiar with it you can see what it
does so what do a random signal I give I
just create a list of lot of random
integers the same input if the input is
say 60 is going to give a 60 output so
basically that's the core code that's
going to know that I'm going to deploy
on that microcontroller then I get to
the microcontroller specifications
itself it's an atmega one six eight
twenty eight bin dual inline package
microcontroller the input is on pin 24
and it's a type analog input the output
is on pin 15 and it's also an analog
output and this is the sampling period
of the frequency you want to sample it
at the appropriate time as you'll see it
blinking it needs to be really fast so
the way I've set it up is
so this microcontroller has a clock of
one megahertz so the sampling period I
use is one foot of that so it's very
fast and now I'm going to deploy it and
now I'm using this external programmer
this is the USB SB programmer that's
what I have here external program are
going to USB SD so this like this I
wired to the programming pins of the of
the microcontroller and this end I'm
going to stick so that's what I'm going
to stick into
yes I was going to send this okay so now
you see two LEDs that means it has
generated the source code does generate
the source code and deployed it so based
on the analog input it dims and and
brighten so this is a basic example and
the whole ideas now I can unplug this
and now this is a completely standalone
microcontroller so we took that whole
firm code and from there we went
directly onto the so this is a gist of
what the microcontroller kit does take
one language code and deployed into
standalone what are you seeing as like
the applications for this yes so the
applications are in the area of so if
you have a controller that you want to
deploy or you have a filter from signal
passing or if you have a model for
hardware in the loop simulation or you
want to do data acquisition so all these
areas this is relevant because when we
designed the controller we don't have to
then go and write the code again we do
the design and we deploy it and
typically we don't get the design right
the first time
so we can eat and so this this
functionality provides a very
very handy way to go about doing the
design and deploying it - so what are
your future plans for this project yes
so we want to add as many
microcontrollers as possible and so we
are getting back use of feedback and
seeing how to prioritize what we want to
develop next and they're also creating
more application examples so people can
see how to use this in their respective
areas so if people want to learn more
where can they learn yes oh so we
created so we have this feature page for
version 12 so this is like a 10,000 for
you it's a summary which gives all the
various features of this micro panatar
look at if they want to go into more
debt they have this this guide page is
also in a product and it has the it has
the function micro control embed code we
just have one main function so if you go
to that ref page like so each one of
this feature we have an example
explaining explaining how they can use
it if they want to use digital input
there's a schematic and detailed code
how to see how to get a go about doing
that they want to go into more detail we
have tutorials which again explains this
in even more details than more detail
than that basic example and then we have
application examples that we put in here
but people can look at these application
examples and get started so this is both
online and also in product support I see
you have another board with you yes just
another example yeah so this one is what
I'm going to present at my talk later
later this week so forth yeah so what
what this is so what this is as a color
sensor and we here you see this array so
that is a array of photodiodes so some
of the diodes are clear some of them are
red filtered some of them are blue and
some of them are green filter so
depending on the light that forth that
falls on it is going to generate current
and for a preset amount of time we
integrate add those currents and that's
going to give a measure of how much red
green or blue fall or clear falls on the
sensor yeah so we first deploy code and
then we can actually see what what
colors it's so this is the code
start again over here I have this
nonlinear lence so this is an
input-output model earlier we had
transfer function model so these are the
Queen four inputs that are coming in the
Clear Channel the red the raw red venue
the rod green and the raw blue value if
it's below a certain threshold that
means it's not seen anything he just
assumed it's black then otherwise we
just do the amount of there are various
ways you can do it and that's what I'm
going to be presenting at my talk but
here this is just one way I'm going to
use a library that's provided by
Adafruit sensor so I say the location of
the library what are the header files to
include and I'm going to create this
either from GCS 3 475 object I'm
creating I said that integration time
I'm going to specify how much time I
want it to be integrated what is the
gain of that and then I'm going to begin
when this court is deployed here it's
going to knows this microcontroller when
that code is deployed onto this
microcontroller it's going to start
communicating to this device and this is
I forgot to mention this is an I squared
C device so it just uses two wires to
communicate and these two are just the
power lines so this is the next piece of
code is what is running in a loop so
these are the raw red green blue and the
clear values so I used this function get
raw data to get it so the first one is
the clear and then I get the red green
and blue and then the output the three
output the red green and blue values I
send it back from the microcontroller
over serial and then I'm going to use
the device framework brush we read those
serial values sending the sensor data
back
yeah so once we deployed this code as
before it can be standalone and then any
other microcontroller with serial
connection can read that data we can use
Arduino to read it or another program
like screen to read that data so here
we're using me we use
language again so this is the complete
microcontroller specification and
I have a function that opens and reads
you see now it's not seeing anything
okay so all the red green and blue
I see so what's already a little yeah so
the grreat rent is predominant and then
there are some if I pick something like
in yellow see again that the red and the
green and then there's a little bit of
blue and I can bring an all-white yes
there are various ways to do it ten each
I've not got a chance to talk much about
the I sweat see in my my presentations
on the microcontroller bit so I I'm
gonna take this opportunity at this
conference to talk about that that's
also do you have anything else that
you'd like to add
no nothing in particular alright thank
you so much for coming in and talking
with us alright thank you
[Music]